cet été marquée par la coved 19 ans
rapprocher les québécois de la nature et
plusieurs personnes qui ont décidé de
revenir connectés pardon avec la pêche
donc pour la recherche et on s'attend
quand même un bel engouement déjà en
magasin la frénésie se fait sentir
on constate un achalandage important
c'est incroyable je n'ai jamais vu en
disant moi je te dirai dans mon col
c'est impressionnant à certains endroits
les vendeurs ou même de la difficulté à
répondre aux demandes des clients
le canada était étant au nord des états
unis qui produit les armes à feu enfin
de façon mondiale et aussi les munitions
on est présentement à court de stock au
secours parce qu'ils en ont pas vraiment
en produits pendant la corrida c'est
qu'ils en gardent eux aussi de leur côté
ne une achats massifs de gens au niveau
des armes à feu des munitions cette
année qu'avec 19 oblige le ministère a
dû élargir la technique d'enregistrement
du gibier sauf exception les stations a
été remplacé par un formulaire en ligne
afin d'éviter les déplacements et
d'alléger le processus ça va les
simplifier parce que avant ce qu'il
fallait se rendre dans une station où
l'enregistrement est permis et je te
dirai que au saguenay il ya deux
endroits comme tel alors il est arrivé
des matins où il y avait des attentes
d'une heure trente deux heures et je te
dirais que c'est un commodat même si
cette initiative pourrait ouvrir la
porte au braconnage le ministère ne
crois pas que ça devienne un problème et
permettre l'enregistrement en ligne
ça n'a pas vraiment d'impact sur le
braquage à dire que ce sont des gens qui
de toute façon on enregistre et repas
compris
on compte sur les chasseurs qui sont
habitués alors que la chasse est
restreint dans la plupart des régions de
la province l'honnêteté des chasseurs
est encore plus importante
moi j'ai confiance et s'il ya des
indésirables qui ont des comportements
qui sont pas des quoi bon faire comme à
l'habitude on va on va appeler les
agents de la faune
même si cela peut sembler difficile par
moment le ministère rappelle qu'il est
important de respecter les mesures de
distanciation physique pendant à toute
la saison
que vous soyez à l'affût de votre proie
ou que vous transportiez votre gibier il
s'est fait les pleurs radio canada
saguenay